من هنا من ضواحي موسكو بدات عام 2007 اول
كتيبه للجيش الروسي عملها مزوده بمنظومه
اس 400 دراجون بول التي تعني الانتصار هي
منظومه صاروخيه ذات قدره سريعه على ملاحقه
اهداف واحد
ومصممه لتدمير الطائرات والصواريخ
الباريستيه والبحريه المجنحه
تتكون من ثلاثه اجزاء جزء يضم ثمانيه
وحدات مضاده للطائرات
12 منصه اطلاق والجزء الثاني يضم انظمه
القياده والتوجيه وردرات اضافه الى جزء
مرتبط بالدعم الفني والصيانه
وتحتاجه ما بين 50
وضعيه الرصد والهجوم
كما يحتاج اطلاق الصاروخ الواحد الى ثلاث
دقائق فقط ويستجيب النظام للهدف في اقل من
10 ثواني
في صواريخ المنظومه القدره على اكتشاف
الاهداف الجويه على بعد 600 كلم ولها قدره
على تدمير الاهداف الايرون ديناميكيه على
بعد ثلاثه كيلومترات وحتى 240 كم
بينما تستطيع تدمير الاهداف الباليسيه على
بعد خمسه كيلو مترات وحتى 60 كم
تحلق بارتفاع ادنى يبلغ 100 متر عن سطح
الارض ويمكنها الوصول الى ارتفاعات عاليه
تصل الى
27400 متر في الثانيه
72 صاروخا في ان واحد
ولكنها تدميره 36 هدفا جويا فقط في الوقت
نفسه
بخمسه انواع من الصواريخ المختلفه
المهامتها القصيره والمتوسطه والطويله بين
40 و 120
هاتين و50 و400 كلم من ابرز الطائرات التي
يمكن استهدافها بالمنظومه الطائره الشبح
والقادفات الاستراتيجيه وطائره الاستطلاع
والانذار المبكر والطائرات المسيره وقدر
مسؤولون في البنتاجون سعر منظومه اس 4
بنحو 500 مليون دولار بينما يصل سعر
بطاريتين من صواريخ باتريوت الامريكيه الى
مليار دولار وسعر منظومه هذا المضاده
للصواريخ الى ثلاثه مليار دولار وهو ما
يعكس حجم المنافسه الروسيه الامريكيه في
هذا المضمار
[موسيقى]